(emergency alert tone)
- I only respond when
there's an emergency.
- Nope. There you go.
Okay. Thanks everybody. I'm just kidding.
(emergency alert tone)
- [Reporter] On October 4th,
hundreds of millions of cell phones
across the US received a text
message and that alert tone
as part of a test of the
National Emergency Alert System.
- So many of us grew up
with the emergency
broadcast system, right?
- [Narrator] This is a test.
This station is conducting a test
of the emergency broadcasting system.
This is only a test.
- Getting that tone on
your TV that interrupted
whatever program you were watching.
This is just the modern version of that
going to people's cell phones.
- [Reporter] Nationwide
alerts for mobile devices
were in the works since the
September 11th, 2001, terrorist attacks,
but didn't become operational until 2012.
Federal law requires the government to
conduct a nationwide test
at least every three years.
The purpose of the test is to ensure
that the emergency response
systems continue to
be effective means of warning
the public about emergencies.
This is the third time
FEMA has conducted a
wireless nationwide test of
all cell phone emergency alerts
but a second test to all cellular devices.
- Getting alerts out
promptly to our communities
saves lives.
That's why FEMA is working
with the Federal Communications Commission
and your local public safety
authorities on this test.
- [Reporter] There are
four different types
of wireless emergency alerts;
national or presidential
alerts, which can only be issued
by the president during
a national emergency,
imminent threat alerts involving hazards
on the local level, like extreme weather,
AMBER alerts about missing
or abducted children
and Public safety alerts,
which have information
about threats that may not be as imminent.
More than 1600 federal, state,
and local authorities use what's known
as the integrated public alert
and warning system or,
IPAWS, to issue alerts
and warnings to people
in their jurisdictions.
Most cell phones powered on
within reach of a cell phone tower
and participating in wireless
service should be triggered
by the national test.
Television shows and
radio broadcasts will also
be interrupted with an
emergency test message.
Only local emergency
alerts like AMBER alerts
or severe weather warnings
can be disabled in advance.
- You cannot opt out of a national alert
and that's because it is
sent by the president.
So if the president is
deciding to send an alert
it's considered important
enough that you should
receive it no matter what.
Aside from test alerts,
the president has not,
to my knowledge, ever
sent a national alert.
- [Reporter] While the
National Alert System
has only been tested,
authorities have used
the system locally more
than 84,000 times since
2012, making it a challenge
for authorities to decide
how often to hit send.
- You know, they're constantly
trying to find that balance
of what's too much and what's too little.
If you don't send enough alerts,
then you might not be reaching everyone.
Versus if you send too many,
you might desensitize people.
There's very much that balance,
or that needle that
they're trying to thread.
- [Reporter] For FEMA, the
nationwide test is a chance
to make sure the federal government
can alert the entire country
in the event of a nationwide emergency.
- We want to make sure that when it counts
we can keep you informed.
The next alert you receive
could save your life
or the life of ones you love.
(soft music)